It's great to welcome to the program today,
Lewis Raven Wallace, author and creator of
The View From Somewhere.
A book and podcast about the myth of objectivity
in journalism. Also, co-founder of Press on
Southern Media Collective. Thanks for your
time during during these strange times. I
guess I would say.
Hey, yeah.
Or so to begin with. I will sometimes get
these beautiful emails from people in my audience
who say, David, I love that you are not biased
in your reporting. And while I will gladly
accept any compliment, it concerns me a little
bit from a media literacy perspective because
I do an opinion program. I am not doing reporting.
I'm doing commentary. And the program is very
much biased in the sense that it is my opinion
and my opinion is certainly partisan. So can
you start to talk about some of the categorization
of media that needs to be done and that maybe
not everybody is doing as well as they should?
Yeah. That's such a cool and weird anecdote
that really sounds familiar to me in that
I think there's been this sort of bending
of the concept of media bias over time to
the point that, you know, a lot of us think
that biased media is just anything we don't
like. Right. Or don't agree with or that doesn't
like vibe with us. Yes. And and so I you know,
a part of my sort of thesis has been to just
get rid of this idea that media bias itself
is the problem and accept that all media in
some way is biased.
Right. We have a frame, we have an ideology.
We have not, you know, not necessarily a partisan
political stance, but often that, too, that
we're bringing to anything that we produce
as as journalists. And so it's less about
trying to be unbiased and more about doing
a really rigorous investigation of what our
own biases and perspectives are and being
transparent about those. And so it sounds
like, you know, the audience members you're
hearing from, they trust you. Yes. And they
might trust you in part because of that transparency.
And so overall, that that's a good thing.
But I think. An important sort of shift for
us right now is to move away from this conflation
of objectivity or nonpartisanship or being
non-biased with being trustworthy because
they are not inherently the same. And I think
those concepts have become really muddled
in a way that's actually really damaging.
Can you talk a little bit about objectivity
versus neutrality, which is sometimes a source
of confusion? And the way I've talked about
it is I could be neutral on the issue of whether
vaccines cause autism or I could be objective,
which is to transparently tell you that all
the science tells us that they don't and that
that's the way I try to explain it. But there's
probably a better umbrella way to talk about
that difference.
Yeah, sure. So, you know, I am.
I am A.I. objectivity and neutrality, but
I think that there is again, a way in which
those concepts have been conflated over time,
where objectivity might be narrowly understood
as sort of what you're talking about.
You know, rigorous kind of scientific approach
to analyzing the facts in an honest attempt
to reflect the closest version of truth that
we can come up with. Right. And but more broadly,
it's often been interpreted to also mean that
the reporter or the outlet is neutral on the
issue or in some way impartial on the issue
or or stands outside of it in some way. And
that's been sort of the journalism school
interpretation of objectivity as well for
a long time, is that it's a reflection of
neutrality. For me, I think even just that,
the idea that there is one objective truth
does kind of fall apart. You know, philosophically
at a certain point and leaves us stuck with
some of the same issues that neutrality does
of like how can we ever fully stand outside
of something and look at it objectively? And
I don't think that that's possible, but I
do think that rigor, transparency, being meticulous
and being, you know, striving for some version
of the truth is something that journalists
can and should still embrace and that that
we do need to separate that out from some
sort of performance of neutrality or performance
of impartiality that has been demanded of
many journalists.
Yet the performative nature of neutrality
is an interesting way to put it. And I think
maybe to think about that a little bit. One
can visualize the sort of corporate legacy
media segments about, for example, climate
change, where you have two guests, one of
two meetings, 50 percent represents the scientific
view. One of two 50 percent represents some
other view. Right. China created it. It's
a hoax or whatever that is. To me, that's
performative neutrality in the sense that
it's 50/50 in this very basic sense, but it
does not reflect anything about what's actually
happening out there in the scientific or factual
community. Why has corporate media decided
to do that? Is it as simple as avoiding criticism
more from one political side than the other,
or is there more to it?
So, yes, avoiding criticism is one piece.
You know, I've heard people say that journalists,
for all that we are willing to go after other
people, are some of the most thin skinned
folks around, which is neither here nor there
to me. But but I think there are larger forces
at play.
That has always been true in this sort of
performance of objectivity and neutrality,
that it originated with a business model based
on advertising.
So advertisers wanted to appeal to the largest
possible sort of general audience, but also
often an audience that has money, that has
resources. Right. So that might have also
translated or still translate to mean white
upper middle class audience.
And so sort of striking a balance of perform
neutrality or performed impartiality that
hits right at the middle of that target audience
is a priority for advertisers and underwriters
and sponsors that certainly, you know, TV
news has taken extremely, extremely seriously
this performance. But I also wouldn't underestimate,
you know, it's not pure economic forces.
There are also political forces in particular
on the right that have worked very hard for
going on five decades now to sort of frame
the concept of balance in terms of left, right,
and then delineate a right wing perspective
that is actually very, very extreme as something
normal and normative and demand that that
perspective be represented and quote unquote,
balanced media. So the example that you gave
about climate change climate deniers are this
tiny, tiny minority. Right. Certainly in the
scientific community, but also are a minority
in the general populace in the United States.
And so the demand that they always be represented
in a conversation about climate change is
a huge win for the sort of corporate right
wing media machine that has pushed to make
that happen. And, you know, this sort of performance
of objectivity, performance of balance and
the demand of that is so dangerous in the
hands of demagogs. And that's what we're dealing
with now. Right. Is journalists sitting around
talking about whether or not to say that Donald
Trump is lying because it might be perceived
as partisan to say that he has lied when he
has lied. And you know what could be more
toxic to the cause of truth than that interpretation
or that performance of objectivity and to
have journalists in mainstream newsrooms sitting
around having that conversation, which they
are, is such a huge win for far right activists
who want that to be the debate rather than
the truth to be told. And then we debate the
real issues from there.
Yeah, as a very brief aside, there's a great
book which may not even be in print anymore
called The Waves of Rancor, which describes
a lot of the backstory on how that was built
up initially. But so you mentioned this question
of do we say that Donald Trump is lying or
do we not? Recently we've seen CNN doing some
sort of like fact checking graphically with
notes at the bottom of the screen during the
Corona virus press briefings. Can you talk
a little bit about the effect that the mainstreaming
of the term fake news as sort of as a cudgel
has had on journalism and media?
Yeah, sure. So, you know, that mainstreaming
of the term fake news and Donald Trump's sort
of use of it, as you said, as a as a cudgel,
has been a powerful tool for advancing this
sort of warping of the debate.
And this demand that every discussion be balanced
with with both far right ideology or in some
cases now just Donald Trump's ideas, whatever
they may be. But that also that is part of
a long standing tradition right in the in
the United States that has always been tied
up with racism and white supremacy. And so
the example that I give in my book is this
idea of the lost cause in the Civil War. And
so, you know, the civil war was at least in
part about ending slavery, and slavery was
a terror on the people who were enslaved.
You know, and I'm sure I don't need to tell
you that. But almost immediately after the
end of the civil war, this sort of news story
was written about who these white southerners
were who were fighting for the Confederacy
and what they were about, and that they weren't
about slavery or enslavement at all. But,
you know, they just wanted states rights and
their lost war.
Was this lost cause of of states rights that
had nothing to do with racism. And and in
the late eighteen hundreds and early nineteen
hundreds. Activists for this sort of lost
cause narrative demanded balance and textbooks.
Right. And demanded that schools in favor
of not being less biased actually teach this
story that you know, slavery had been this
sort of benign thing and that it wasn't really
what Civil War was about. And these nice white
people just wanted their states rights. And,
you know, and they were nice to the black
people anyway. And all this kind of B S, right.
But that's like the original fake news like
this sort of you know, it's a lost cause and
it's biased to teach it as something that
was actually about racism. And so that strategy
has been used by racist demagogs in the United
States since forever. And that's just one
example of it. Donald Trump is part of a long
tradition and, you know, unfortunately has
amassed a great deal of power. But he's not
the first racist demagog to amass power.
Certainly not really. So in the limited time
we have left, I would love to hear from you.
What do you see as the lowest hanging fruit
of if we could start teaching media literacy
in seventh grade, which I think would be a
great time to start teaching it? Three things
I think would be really useful would be teaching.
Number one, understand the primary purpose
of a news source, which would very quickly
get you to well, if the primary purpose is
to make money, that needs to be included in
my analysis. Number two, understanding whether
you're looking at a primary source or not.
And the number three, distinguishing between
opinion journalism and news journalism, those
that's just an example. And there could be
many other examples. What do you see if you
get a classroom of 12 year olds in front of
you as the lowest hanging fruit that would
do the most good as far as media literacy
goes?
Those are great. I love your three points.
I think that my big takeaway not just for
children but for adults and this is great
if we can start I mean, young is just curiosity,
right?
That there's always another question. There's
always follow up. So I think we end up being
fed this perception that what you read in
the news or what you hear on the news is sort
of. That's it. That's the final story and
the myth of objectivity feeds into that. There
are these objective people out there who are
journalists who just bring you the story and
that's everything that you might need to know.
And either you trust them or you don't.
But I think all of us right now really need
to be working our muscle of curiosity and
of always asking more questions and investigating
further into things and essentially sort of
become journalists in a way ourselves. Certainly
the crisis of Cauvin 19 and then pandemic
has been an opportunity for that. People are
seeing in real time how journalistic fact
and truth actually isn't set in stone. It
changes pretty quickly in an environment where
even scientists don't know what this virus
is. Right. And so all of our ability to be
curious and open minded and to actually change
the way that we think about something based
on new information and ask new questions over
time, to me, that's sort of the core for both
people taking in media and for people producing
it is that we can all embody more of that
curious journalists or curious scientists
and that a scientist or a journalist. The
point of that person is not that they have
the best answers, but that they have the best
questions. And I think that's often misunderstood
and process is important.
Right, understanding that because something
that was said about the virus six weeks ago
ended up not being true doesn't mean someone
was necessarily lying. It could mean that.
But we are sort of iterating. Science is an
iterative process. So is journalism and understanding
that because that's also weaponized sometimes
to say the thing they told us six weeks ago
was wrong. Therefore, Bill Gates is trying
to get a vaccine to sterilize people or whatever.
It's all on the table because something was
corrected. The process part seems so important.
Yeah, and understanding that process of investigation
and inquisitiveness, and I think that's one
of the most important things that we could
be teaching in terms of media literacy, is
that that's all that news is. Right. Is the
best attempt at providing facts and information
of a group of people who brought it to you
today.
We've been speaking with Lewis Raven Wallace,
author and creator of The View From Somewhere.
A book and podcast about the myth of objectivity
in journalism. So great having you on. I really
appreciate your time.
Thank you for having me.